what I will do is have a grow hackers
yeah okay what I will just have a
grown-ass conversation with you are
those fighting words let's talk about it
Rachel Lindsay and cold Underwood's
social media feud is apparently just
getting started
let's take a look at how we got here the
war between the two Bachelor franchise
stars began during Rachel's recent
appearance on watch what happens live
with Andy Cohen during the show a fan
called in to ask her about the
falling-out between her and former
bachelor contestant Raven gates what did
she do to conjure falling out I can't
say I thought they'd say but it was
enough for me to not want to be friends
with her anymore and you're still not
friends with her no and I never will be
although it's still unclear about what
caused the rift between the two colton
seemed to be the least surprised when
commenting on the clip on instagram
saying
shocker rachel mad at another person
does she like anyone he also added that
he's not quote weighing in on the Rachel
Sasha Raven drama I could care less
about that not my business what is my
business is a countless number of times
she spoke poorly at me including the
time she ran her mouth about me to
Cassie
funny thing is I've never met her so
what did Rachel say to Colton's
girlfriend Cassie Randolph on the witan
ride YouTube series Rachel said when
meeting Cassie in July they both hit it
off and Cassie admitted to her that she
is soon Rachel didn't like Colton I
remember say I'm just do different I
just don't believe I have to be best
friends with everybody just because we
all come from the same TV show I said my
thing has always been with Colton that
felt like I never really knew who he was
and so I just wish I got to understand
the real him Rachel also mentioned she
doesn't think there's any bad blood
between her and Cassie but when it comes
to Colton she clearly didn't appreciate
him taking the drum at social media
didn't help is Colton commenting and you
know I would love for Colton to actually
come on the podcast because what I'm not
gonna do is entertain you in the comment
section of somebody else's post what I
will do is have a grow Hecker's yeah
okay what I will just have a grown-ass
conversation with you and we can talk
about it Colton responded to Rachel on
Twitter agreeing to come on the podcast
quote on one condition
ask your producers to leave it raw
unedited and untouched
looking forward to meeting you in
pointing out your hip-hop
see over the last year I want to say
anything and have it be taken out of
context I sort of want you guys to just
be on the roller coaster with me
[Music]
[Applause]